[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce journal de
la rédaction de tv 78 l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale de ce vendredi à 27
décembre les fêtes de noël rime souvent
avec pénurie de sens c'est le constat
fait par l'établissement français du
sang
cette année l'impact des mouvements
sociaux depuis le 5 décembre dernier
couplée à la période des congés les
épidémies saisonnières ont mis les
stocks dans le rouge
le ffs lance donc un appel en cette
période pour collecter les 1700 dons
quotidiens nécessaires chaque jour en
ile-de-france pour répondre à la demande
si vous voulez donner votre sang une
collecte sera notamment organisée à
magnanville le samedi 28 décembre de 10
heures à 15 heures en salle des familles
plus renseignements sur le site internet
de l'établissement français du sang
c'est l'un des rendez vous sportifs
phares de cette fin d'année à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pendant quatre
jours les joueurs y vinoy s'affrontent
aux échecs le club la dame noire de
montigny le bretonneux organise un
tournoi avec à la clé mille euros un
concours ouvert à tous les âges et à
tous les niveaux
un reportage de mathilde de 2010
le silence règne dans l'école erik satie
à montigny le bretonneux au fond du
couloir les clubs d'échecs des yvelines
se sont réunis pour s'affronter lors du
tournoi de la dame noire
un niveau relativement extrêmes on a des
jeunes et des joueurs pas forcément très
fort c'est des joueurs de clubs qui sont
licenciés et pas forcément très fort
angers un espace dans une bonne ambiance
et c'est aussi ça que les gens
apprécient dans le tournoi les visages
sont fermés et concentré les joueurs
sont en pleine réflexion pour protéger
leur reine est effectuée au plus vite un
échec et mat à son adversaire
ma première partie c'est une victoire
j'ai joué contre une personne qui était
plutôt très agressive la partie était
serrée et puis par des petites erreurs
de l'adversaire ça m'a emmené
directement vers la victoire un pour moi
qui se veut conviviale et bon enfant
avec cette partie en quatre jours pour
les plus performants une remise de
chèque aura lieu à la fin du concours
erwan lui ne vise pas la victoire mais
essaye de se faire sa place au
classement
j'ai commencé à jouer aux échecs ce fait
à peu près deux ans je jouais surtout en
ligne mais j'avais envie de deux joueurs
auraient rencontré des adversaires pour
progresser le plus possible
un tournoi qui a lieu depuis 20 ans avec
l'objectif de rassembler tous les
joueurs et viennois passionnés de
l'échiquier un mot de boxe à présent
ahmed el moussaoui a repart au combat le
ver héros affronte ce samedi soir au
palais des sports de marseille le russe
va guina quête abrasion dans la
catégorie des poids welters sportif yves
binois de 29 ans sera favori de ce
combat il n'a perdu que trois fois en 35
affrontements alors que son adversaire
s'est incliné à six reprises en 16
combats ahmed el moussaoui nous explique
sa stratégie on l'écoutait faudra être
vigilant et surtout et c'est de ne pas
se faire marcher dessus et puis garder
gardel centre du ring tout en essayant
de contrer ces attaques
la stratégie c'est de maintenir à
distance le faire déclencher puis
contre-attaqué derrière après bon ça
reste une stratégie on va essayer de
rester dessus même si on sait que ça
peut changer à tout moment
on referme cette page sports part du un
cyclisme c'est désormais une habitude la
course paris-nice s'élancera pour la
onzième année consécutive depuis les
yvelines d'après nos informations les
coureurs partiront le dimanche 8 mars
prochain depuis plaisir pour traverser
une partie du département
le lendemain l étape partira depuis
chevreuse pour rejoindre le loiret le
parcours sera office
le mans dévoilé le 8 janvier prochain
versailles on écoute le vice président
de la fédération française jean michel
richefort paris-nice et la course au
soleil
c'est la première grande course
internationale de la saison avec tirreno
adriatico et bien sûr la belle et les
meilleurs mondiaux seront au rendez vous
et c'est important d'avoir les plus
grandes les les plus grands coureurs
mondiaux au départ bien sur paris nice
c'est une très très grande course
internationale
[Musique]
les fêtes de fin d'année sont souvent à
synonyme de sortie à cinéma mélanie poké
vous proposons sont 7,8 loisirs quelques
films à visionner à regarder les
vacances c'est aussi l'occasion d'aller
au cinéma quatre idées de films à voir
dans les jours qui viennent le premier
est à découvrir en famille les
incognitos conte l'histoire du super
espion lens sterling et du scientifique
walter beckett alors qu'une mission
tourne mal ils vont devoir unir leurs
formes force une interlude musical avec
l'adaptation de 4 c'est la célèbre
comédie musicale et mise en image par
tom hooper l'occasion d'écouter à
nouveau le magnifique memory et dans la
nouvelle angleterre des années 1860 un
parent père un père part pour un voyage
laissant ses filles et sa femme derrière
lui ces dernières vous faire à la
connaissance du jeune loris vous aurez
sans doute reconnu l'histoire des quatre
filles du docteur march les romans de
louisa may alcott sont à nouveau mises
en images est le dernier à vivre avec un
peu de nostalgie dans play max reçoit à
13 ans un caméscope et pendant 25 ans il
n'arrêtera pas de film est un portrait
de toute une génération et on regarde
des experts
face aux stars
jma sur un truc chez moi tu va
révolutionner l'espionnage
définitivement ça s'appelle la
dissimulation biodynamique imaginer que
j'arrive à vous faire attention
attention roulements de tambour
disparaître
[Musique]
m
le sort
nos filles ont tendance à faire des
sottises
alors moi aussi voici meg et me baisse
et john
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien réussir par moi-même à
personne ne réussit jamais seul
surtout pas de femme tu dois faire un
bon mariage merci papa merci maman ce
cadeau un paillage en votre qualité ont
très vite des chronos à la moyenne c'est
la fin de ce journal merci l'avoir suivi
retour à lundi prochain de l'actualité
locale passer un excellent week-end sur
tv à 78
[Musique]